[Music]
have you guys
ever tried to disguise something
of value that you have uh
to make it less uh appealing for people
to steal
yes baby one more time have you made it
some
have you made something like less
valuable looking so then people won't
jack it
kind of like you have a really pretty
girl but then you want her to like dress
kind of down so other guys won't go for
her exactly
baggy pants baggy everything i cover all
my [ __ ] when i'm in the car and i go in
inside like if i have anything cool i
cover it with like garbage
yeah it's kind of like i i seen when he
picks up nikki and she gets in the car
he throws garbage on her right throw
hers right on the guys aren't looking at
her and they don't like try to pull it
through the car or anything yeah
true good hubby thank you
uh in japan a man a 29 year old man
named
motoki ryoga from saitama japan
he designed a sticker that looks like
bird poop in order for you to put that
sticker
on uh on your bike in order for people
not to steal it
and then he told everyone he made this
product yes he did
that's kind of like the people who have
these caps
and underneath you can hide your weed oh
no [ __ ] what
yeah i see that again like cups and like
they have like spray bottles
yeah hairspray yeah that's tight windex
this is more like
having fake vomit like like making fake
vomit and then putting it on your laptop
so
no one touches it that is so cute he's
assuming that a burglar
will look at this and go ew i'm not
gonna steal that
exactly i don't want to put my butt on
that yucky
i thought no crime happened in japan
yeah well that's
my immediate thought i was like oh yeah
isn't japan super safe i think what
happens is somebody thought it was their
bike
because all the bikes look the same the
accidental crime all the people look the
same there so all the bikes
so it's really it's really though all
the bikes actually look the same
all the bikes actually it's very cool
yeah yeah i wouldn't say that
i think they all look like that's a
little insane yeah bikes are all
different
it's cute that that's the uh that's like
the deterrent because like all the cars
are so pristine there's like no
layer of dust especially so that's like
the only way he can like dirty it
because it's just
[ __ ] impeccable that's true does it
look real enough to you guys
uh i'm like like at a glance i don't
know if i was gonna steal a bike
i'd steal that one you steal that one
then it works
yeah i guess it doesn't work yeah i'm
like i'm scoping convenience yeah i
don't want that one
never mind yeah i just got these pants
that's true
so yeah so he um he was dealing with the
situation where
um according to research a bike in japan
is stolen
every 15 minutes so they're all
interested
i'm sorry so uh of the 35
395 stolen bikes in 2018 42 percent of
them were locked
properly as well so in terms of like
just regular
you know security for yourself
everyone's using the same password
oh maybe they've seen them
you know what's wild you know like by
the train station they do have these
bark uh bike parking spots right
so when you walk in none of them are
[ __ ] locked
like i don't i don't i never see a lock
on them and i'm just like you can
literally just grab one of these and get
the [ __ ] out of here
and it's a japanese like dream come true
japan is thieves out there oh japanese
don't go no don't go to japan get on
this [ __ ]
place to steal dude bike thief he's like
the place to go this is this place is
the place yeah it's got the horde it's
got everything
like you can imagine there's no locks i
mean think about the number right
42 of the people had their bike
locked that guy that
still got stolen that still got stolen
right so in america
it's like 110 have their bikes locked
and it got stolen yeah true dude
remember when we were in japan and we
walked into this house thinking it was
our airbnb and it was just
unlocked like oh yeah yeah the crew
walked into this house
so we were rolling deep like 20. there
was 20 people that walked into that
house
i guess this is our airbnb and like it
was confusing as [ __ ] where the numbers
were in the street we were having a hard
time nighttime too so we couldn't see
we go into the and the doors open we're
like oh okay i guess it must be they
must have left it open for us for us to
you know enter the airbnb we go in i was
outside so i was at the
end of the of this trail of people you
know but then everyone started turning
back my way i was like
wow we're not gonna some of us already
turned the corner and
like we went up the stairs turned the
corner we saw the glow of a tv
and we're like oh [ __ ] there's people
here having dinner
did they see you dinner yeah i saw them
have dinner they didn't say hi
i saw him around the corner and i'm like
oh [ __ ] let's go back and we went back
did they see you at all
no they have no idea they had no idea
yeah no one came after
like nothing that's so scary even hear
all of us talking
we were loud you could have been a
roving gang of rapists it was the
quietest neighborhood
ever and we were [ __ ] loud with 20
people you guys were in a really nice
area
though my mom was like oh they're
staying there damn that place is balling
and i'm like really we're bougie yeah we
were trying to find the biggest house
possible so i guess for japan standards
we were in a mansion that's true
it was pretty nice to fit the whole
company in there true
but yeah so uh that's crazy though
a bike is stolen every 15 minutes every
15 minutes so yeah so
motoki he conducted a social experiment
where he placed a thousand of these
stickers
on a thousand bikes and locked him up
properly and everything
and owned these bikes crazy i don't you
know yeah how did he get his hands
on about maybe it's other people's bikes
maybe he's just like it's looking good
i'm just gonna put it on your bike
do this experiment can i put a bird [ __ ]
and he's like okay okay just like that
okay yeah it's just to think
this is like a child's repel like a way
to repel something like yeah it's like
the most
simplest way no one's gonna want bird
[ __ ]
like take the damn seat off or something
take the seat with you
or what if he saw it in action where
there's a guy who's stealing a bike
and there's bird poop on he goes
why did you not do this he's like that
is our one weakness it's bike thieves
we do not not bird poop no bird poop
it's like it's like garlic with
vampires you know bike thieves and bird
[ __ ] don't get along
or plot twists he is a bike thief and
that's what deters him
oh he's like i gave away our trade
secret
i'm cashing out i mean if you think
about it right
if most of the bikes are unlocked
they're not going to choose the one with
bird [ __ ] because there's another bike
right there that's unlocked so they're
going to grab that one
with double security have you guys ever
watched the lockpicking lawyer on
youtube
no what lockpicking looking lawyer he
can crack a [ __ ] lock
faster than i finish this sentence like
i'm not kidding i've seen him do it like
he can crack a lock in like five seconds
really long though it's not that long
it's pretty windy he can crack
a lock faster than i can finish this
sentence so you just go
he's done does he put his ear to it yeah
he he uh he doesn't he uses a pick can't
be
cracked honestly none so most of the no
seriously
most of the locks that they advertise is
like oh you uncrackable this [ __ ]
he cracks them and makes makes fun of it
i got an idea
what if we have a lock that doesn't
require
a key mm-hmm uh
number one he could still crack it so
and also what geo just said safes he can
crack it
what if i what if i do it and it's like
and then it opens oh i already remember
yeah but it's my hands
they sounded pretty similar those still
have access points that you can crack
what about if it's face scan or like
fingerprints he's cracked all right
he's cracked all of it what about if it
was
what about if it was a combination oh he
cracks the [ __ ] out of those you know
those bike locks where it's like you
have
four
but the combination i'm telling you man
go watch this guy's library because
you'll be like
god damn there's no [ __ ] safety at
all but really what it's about is like
he's an
expert expert expert level and he's just
showing you the vulnerabilities that
exist is he a better
locksmith or a better lawyer then
he's just being full-time why he'd be a
lawyer never see him do legal at all
he probably sucks at it i think that's
his nickname it's not even that he's a
lawyer he's like i've lost
a lot of cases so i have to do youtube
actually i never really try to pick
locks because it was so much easier to
have a
uh those those what do you call those
those plier thingies wire cutters
wire cutters i got one at home
they work great and then another one is
you don't even need to bother with a
lock
you get a flat head screwdriver you jam
it in
and you pry it open oh i bet he could do
that faster than the lawyer with your
sentence the lawyer just
[ __ ] crack 30 during joe's sentence
that's how [ __ ] does he use little
tweezers
he uses a pick he has like this specific
pick that he it's the pig
no no no you have to learn how to use
the pick yeah it's hard well he he has
one that he designed that he released as
well
oh he should he released it for sale
yeah he did but he doesn't really
[ __ ] well no no because people who
watch his videos want to learn how to
crack blocks
what [ __ ] it's fun no well that's
like for fun
i'm kidding because i i i've looked into
it too it's pretty interesting
well maybe they're all um what do you
call it locksmiths
i actually try they unlock for good it's
hard
i've tried unlocking doors too like all
throughout my childhood have
never been able to watch anything well
you gotta know how to do it like pretty
much every person in the special ops
community knows how to get out of
handcuffs
so in their like first aid kit everyone
has a lock the general lock pick maybe
not the specific one that this guy made
but everyone has one and they know how
to pick locks and know how to like
like if you get hostage you know how to
get out so there's at least uh like
there's
a skill level for at least the base
level of lock picking and this guy's
just seems like he knows
every single other one on top of that my
lock picking went into the extent of
getting
a a paper clip and hitting that small
little button
because on the other end when they push
that button to lock it you can unlock it
by going
and then you open the door yeah so over
the course of five days when he placed
the thousand burp stickers on a thousand
bikes
no bikes were stolen wow and now he's
taken
his invention to crowdfunding and uh now
he's raised about four thousand two
hundred thirty four dollars
uh exceeding the original 182
that he was looking for to create uh his
product of stickers
oh my god in your 2021 all the [ __ ]
stats
down because everyone knows the [ __ ]
thing the trick you just peel the bird
[ __ ] off
this is a sticker it's a cute sticker
that's just a sticker they still like
oh i was wrong i don't have a good
sticker eye
or like ten bikes back to back have the
same sticker on and he's like
damn they all got bird [ __ ] i just got
an idea for an upgrade for his
sticker it was just gonna be his like
sticker 2.0 it's going to be one of
those
like in like fillable kind of stickers
that
like you know those those pimples that
you pop as a game and then it goes
everywhere
so if they do sit on it or whatever
it'll like actually have
[ __ ] come out oh yeah oh why not just
create fake bird poop
or no because this time it actually like
spreads and it is like
if it is real poop and they would not
want to actually touch it
i think i think um what people should do
is [ __ ] in tupperware
that's what i was thinking and then when
they get to their location
just park the bike grab the cocka
just rub it on the [ __ ] chair you
have to sit on that chair too
you're dealing with your [ __ ] yeah but
when you come back bring two ass seats
clean it oh what i'm gonna do is when
you get when it's time to ride home
you bring your screwdriver out of your
switch or see what someone else is
down but all the seats are all fun oh no
all the seats look the same they're all
[Music]
brown
you